[Music]
oh baby hello and welcome back to the
break room this is our daily live show
that keeps you updated on all the nerdy
fandom news you need to know sorry if I
picked my mic though you scared me a
little scared in this she almost jumped
out of her seat coming up on the show
today it's a trailer for a Mario someone
wrote that in I had to do it
I did it that was that was a New York
cancel sign uh we're also talking about
Rings and Things uh and we're gearing up
for werewolf by night I'm too scared to
stay up to watch it uh I'm Brady bear
who cares joining me on the show today
we got koi Chandra I just realized
spider-verse would have came out
tomorrow so we would have had Daredevil
werewolf Spider-Man and Black Adam we
were so close before they pushed it back
come on oh my gosh nearly perfect
weekend nearly perfect weekend uh week
wind but if you want a perfect weekend
hang out with Anna vanston hey
don't know where
nowhere oh missing iguana mystery I like
it what do you have to say about it
Tommy Mitchell it's the freaking week
went baby
wind did a great job at the Super Bowl
today the weak wind was amazing
he's a straw boy oh that was good that
was good uh that was so good we're gonna
give Anna the redemptions today hey if
you feel like sending in some super
chats we'll get to your questions we got
a lot of thoughts and a lot of dirty
thoughts about last night's episode of
She-Hulk oh my God but Anna has promised
that for every 100 view raised in super
chat she'll do a little dance
little things a little dance will she
make a little love will she get down
tonight will I do that joke again yes
I'll find out later I'm hoping for a big
number three
third time's the charm I always say
that's right that's right uh you know
what I always say Tommy what's that
headline
by the way guys if you're listening on
headphones turn it down yeah I'm sorry I
can't I can't read any more comments
about how we blew your ears out at this
point it's been a year we're shouting
hey if we're too loud on this show go
ahead and hit that like button huh smash
that like button if we're smashing your
eardrums And subscribe to us yeah
subscribe to us uh we have Internet
please subscribe to the show all 49
states with Wi-Fi we miss you Arkansas
come back Arkansas Jersey oh oh he's
still on the Jersey well I just I'm not
I'm just trying to raise awareness we
got to connect that state we gotta get
him back on the grid
get them back on the grid uh I know you
all were were so in tune today to
today's Nintendo Direct because we
finally got a trailer for the upcoming
Super Mario Bros movie uh and we got a
our first looked at like Mar in an
action of like Bowser Mario Luigi
Toadstool but we also got a little bit
of their voices just the tedious little
taste we all wanted to know we got a lot
of Bowser's voice heard a lot of that uh
what did you guys think of it I thought
it was it looked pretty pretty and it
was very excited for this one here's
okay here's here's the only thing I
don't understand it happened with
someone it could happen with Mario
they've already gotten the gameplay of
the game so good to the point where like
they have a Mario model they have him
like he's right there you can change the
camera angle it's beautiful
you know but I don't know why they make
him look different I just don't know
right I mean a lot less buns he's got no
dump he's got like a real flat it's a
real flat as far as plumbers go they do
a lot of squats real fast
but the plumbing he's squatting and he's
standing
those lunges have seen it yeah yeah John
noticed and I pointed this out too the
fact that he can move so much more
immediately I was like he's moving so
much because there's only so much we can
really move around maybe he's like oh oh
Mario on HGH definitely on
[Applause]
the mushrooms are mushrooms and the
stars are acid I think that's how you
explain oh that makes sense little tabs
great yeah little tabs little tabs
sponsors love this episode
the poster is incredible it's a
beautiful book it brings that much
excitement and adventure and like wow I
I'm gonna be I'm gonna be it'll be very
interesting can't wait to see it gonna
see it in 40x gets splashed with Mario
just throw mushrooms at you oh baby oh
baby I'm gonna see it in y Max oh why is
that uh it's a Swedish uh form of
theater where you go and instead of a
screen uh men shout in your face the
story they just do like an oral history
of it they're like Mario yo runs across
the screen I don't I don't head Bobby
yeah yeah that's the Wario subplot you
want to get an oral story from a bunch
of Swedish men okay
dignified show it's a family show why
does koi have three coffee modes
got a Baker's Dozen box and is blatantly
promoting friends not a sponsor raw dog
and Sprite over here this Show's a
nightmare where's Jessica where's Zach
next headline next headline The
Hollywood Reporter is reporting how
ironic that Netflix made a much larger
offer for the Lord of the Rings than
Amazon Prime did someone outbid Bezos uh
in the end Amazon's Vision aligned most
closely with the Tolkien the state
because there is an estate that still
controls all of tolkien's Works a large
part of Amazon Prime's video Pitch
apparently was uh that their their
adaptation was going to be a pledge of a
close relationship that would give the
estate a creative seat at the table so
it could protect tolkien's Legacy which
is why they went with Amazon's offer of
tens of millions less
tens of millions of less than Netflix is
250 million Netflix is like we're gonna
take 10 sexy dwarves and put them on an
island Rebecca Romaine O'Connell hosts
dwarf Island I would watch I would watch
Elf boy Island
Boy Island
a little bit of a researcher tidbit info
another reason they decided to go with
that route was because Netflix was
pitching like a marvel-esque uh a
multiple show an Airborne show oh like
one about one of the [ __ ] elves yeah
I was like there's some [ __ ] Wizards
guys we can't swear in the first five
minutes and it was an adjective and
these are how's that funk and these are
Wizards
I put them on Disney plus apparently
thank God this is pre-taped thank God
we'll cut all that out we'll fix it
pretends to go live next headline L
magazine has been interviewing the stars
of black panther wakanda forever there
was quite a bit of interesting
information that came out of this uh you
know they were kind of prodding uh the
actors about the fact that like you know
there's a lot of speculation that black
panther might be the next Black Panther
might be a woman you know maybe the fact
that the Black Panther we saw was a
woman that could be wine
it could be a slight man I I like the
idea that it was in Baku in that suit
and he's like give me breasts
are giving deaths give me the suit but
make sure they got Honkers
that chant is it's actually give me
breasts in wakanda uh but they they were
kind of putting out this article that
there's kind of like a petrineal
monarchy of wakanda's first outing and
bringing now they're going to be
bringing the nation into a new era so
it's not so much about Kings anymore but
about like the women kind of taking over
what and uh uh and they point out the
fact that there's a lot of history in
this in the comics right as we all know
Sherry in the comics does become the
Black Panther on various occasions uh
lupito Nyong'o kind of like laughed at
this mischievously she was saying like
the whole time like we love this
speculation uh and they were pointing
out that like no one's really getting
all of it right everyone's speculation
hasn't really landed on what actually
happens uh uh uh Guerrera I'm saying her
name wrong who plays Okoye uh she said
that like no they haven't guessed it all
uh
they haven't figured out what's
happening yet we've kind of speculated
that there's maybe more than one black
panther I think there might be a Baker's
does it a baker doesn't uh yeah grabbery
mug on the table there's five black
panthers uh can we get coin mug can we
fly a mug in Phillips
Phillip can we fly a mug in for koi
supposed to do over here but it is
fascinating to see all this because it
is an idea that like uh oh
he couldn't even come on camera cams the
camera couldn't fit these big muscles
too much the polo can't handle it uh
also in this month's in this month's
Vogue Michaela Cole uh has confirmed
that her character Anika is queer uh she
said that she was really uh sold on the
the role the fact that her character is
queer and she brought up the fact uh
because she is from Ghana uh and like
many African countries Ghana has she
this is a quote from her uh Ghana has
Draconian anti-gay laws dating back to
the Colonial area and most recently
though a bill has been put to Parliament
calling for some of the most oppressive
anti-lgbtq legislation the continent has
ever seen if passed it could make
identifying as gay or even as an ally a
secondary felony punishable by five
years in prison uh and she said that's
kind of why she wanted to do this role
because she wanted to have like a
powerful queer character to show on
screen and she said quote that's why I
felt important for me to step in and do
that role because I know just by me
being ghanian ghanaians will come God
bless uh and I think it's great and I
think she's gonna be awesome she's so
good and uh I may destroy you did I say
that right forget the name of that show
but she's great in that I'm excited to
see what she's doing for her that's
amazing and also by the way uh it's not
just Ghana in Africa we've got people
trying to do that here yeah so you know
all the American actors should equally
be uh taking up those causes because
what an insane time to be alive what an
insane anyway yeah more mugs for quick
Phil can we fly another mugger please I
got political friends
with his own space speaking of I may
destroy you I think my next movie is
going to be titled may I destroy you
say to my dates please
if you want to see Anna's little dance
possibly destroy you keep sending in
those super chats at 100 I will do my
first very small I had a great time at
this Carl's Jr may I destroy you destroy
my apologies to the Carl's Jr bathroom I
will just try it we got a new blurb
about Ruby Williams via the Marvel's
online store this was like Hasbro's
online action figure store if you want
to go look at it you get a very good
look at what the iron Hearts suit one of
the Iron Heart suits is gonna look like
wakanda forever but the blur was very
interesting about this uh action figure
because it's a quote a brilliant MIT
student with a passion for engineering
Riri Williams life takes an unexpected
turn when a school project brings the
wakandans and a dangerous foe to her
doorstep so I went to Disneyland
recently oh my family came home and it
was magical as you know it's a wonderful
place but I noticed on the Spider-Man
ride this time there's an iron Heart
Locker yeah in that array of lockers and
there's also like a moon girl and some
other things I don't know if we'll get
but I did remember that we saw the guy
from Miss Marvel in that setup before we
met him so maybe likewise there is a
school connection with ironheart yeah I
you know we have kind of speculated this
fits with the trailer footage where we
see like akoya and shuri they appear to
be in like an American city which we
thought oh that's probably Chicago uh
but this kind of interesting playing
into how Riri Williams gets involved
with instead of heart-shaped route right
maybe something like what else would
they be coveting maybe something like
that oh we got it oh there it is
I don't know thank you which which one
won the contest I asked which one which
mug uh but yeah this is kind of
fascinating like this is how she's going
to get involved it sounds like they're
there for our school project right but
it also seems like this foe
it's probably not Neymar yeah that I
mean I think they would just name him
right yes so like maybe this is hinting
at who the other villain in this movie
is going to be I don't know me uh this
mysterious beverages not water
oh boy I don't know you're a brave man
to take a drink from Phillip Molina I
don't know if you don't see him pour it
you don't know vaguely tart but also
Little Sweets I was really scared oh
it's got to be
it's got to be maybe one of our
delicious Chiefs it could be a delicious
more on that in just a bit oh uh one
thing producer John Carter found on
Reddit was this user ksa331 kind of
pointing out that rere's role seems very
similar to like Peter Parker's in Civil
War where you have a character who's
like living their normal life and is
already developing this Tech and then
someone comes in with a lot of powerful
uh materials and resources that they can
give them to make their Tech even better
which seems like what's going to happen
in wakanda forever right uh more she has
her own kind of primitive suit is the
wrong thing to say uh Early Edition Mach
1 or prototype soup and then sure he's
like oh you want some nanotech it might
make your life a little easier uh there
you go
um next headline Michael gianchino has
been pitching his uh his idea for uh
werewolf by night to Kevin feige for
over four years four years four years
that's the distance between two Olympics
that's true that's how old I am that's
right you're four years old that's right
no no doing that if you're for get out
of here nobody wants this uh we do have
some clips about this I believe that we
can show well I have been talking to
Kevin feige about this about directing
and he had citizens like maybe I don't
know four years ago and he goes
if you're kind of direct what what do
you want to direct and I was like we're
almost by now I really loved that corner
of the Marvel Universe and no one has
touched it and I was like you guys you
have everything here you have a
Frankenstein's monster you have you know
the two of Dracula you have all you know
the the werewolves you have it all let's
have some fun with that I I think it's
time to do something weird and different
and new and he was just like uh okay and
then suddenly it just started happening
and I was like oh my God is this
happening and they're like yeah we want
us to talk to you about hiring a writer
and this and that and I was like what
and then Covey
and then everything got shut down and
everyone began higher writer sorry and
then it was just like you know you all
know we were all just stuck at home and
I was stuck at home and we were just
like I was like well there goes that and
uh in about a year into it I got a call
from Stephen Broussard and he goes you
still want to make that thing and I was
like yeah yes he goes when we can hire a
writer and and I was like are you
kidding me he's like no but it was like
and it just kept going
oh God
but that is crazy
that Michael jokino worked so hard till
I get this thing made 19 tick tocks
later we are back really nine thousand
words to explain one sentence I was
waiting for the Post credits hey Dad our
good our good friend Dasha worked very
hard to get that footage he had to
pretend to be wearing a pacemaker to get
that camera in there so we appreciate
him for that I think we have another
question if you have the time coming you
have another clip of Michael chiquino or
I legally can't leave until my Pro
officer shows up to pick me up so thanks
for this clip uh this next up is him
kind of explaining the special
presentation of it all well early on I
remember talking with Kevin and he was
saying that remember specials don't you
miss specials like do you remember that
and remember how excited you get when
you when you hear that opening music and
you'd be like and yeah I do remember
that vividly and I remember hearing that
because you knew that something
different was going to be on TV that
night you know and it signaled you
whether it was the Great Pumpkin or
whether it was you know Rudolph it
didn't matter what it was but you knew
it was going to be different from
whatever else you had been trained to
expect during the week and so he was
like why don't we do that and then we
start talking about doing a logo for it
you know and doing a logo and then I
wrote the music for it it was just like
again everything every little bit of
this thing is sort of a love letter to
our youth and the things that that
inspired us
but it's very interesting uh we're all
very excited about werewolf by night uh
bear trap one two four sent in a Super
Chat saying is the werewolf By Night
Watch party a go it is Friday it's not a
watch party but tomorrow we are gonna be
talking werewolf finite make sure you
watch it yeah if you if you if you're
tuning in tomorrow make sure you're all
caught up on werewolf by night we're so
excited to see it I know Cory has seen
it it's in my top and I know it's
controversial but it's in my top four
Face Forward properties period boom he
bumped eternals for this one folks you
know uh and dashel loved it our boy
dashel behind the camera he saw that
film last night in a movie theater with
tons of people half of them didn't even
like Marvel but boy did they like the
movie uh we're very excited to see it
I'm excited to be a scared little boy
you know what they say what they say
werewolf in the morning Sailors be
warning werewolf at night Sailor's
Delight salary
oh the sailors came in from the ocean so
usually I'd say people should watch like
you know if you're gonna watch Black
Panther watch Civil War like people are
always asking for homework I'd like
honestly say you don't need to have seen
any Marvel but you should watch the old
like man wolf and Frankenstein and bride
of Dracula like bad stuff red regular
brighter Frankenstein that era like the
36 practice I got married as well you
did well for himself yeah like it's
really cool that they capture that
flavor in this Frankenstein's the
monster
Frankenstein's monster oh yeah
okay keep going immediately he's always
about to do it because the Universal
Pictures called him Frankenstein is
different you know it's fine it is what
it is but hey if you like to be annoying
to your friends make sure you remind
them it's Frankenstein's monster and not
Frankenstein next headline it's only
Dracula if he's from Transylvania
if you want to be stupid say out of
nowhere Frank it's time to the boss did
you guys know the monastery
I mean he played God he's a bit of a
monster himself isn't he isn't that the
allegory that maybe the monster is the
man the point of the story is that we're
the monsters it's true
uh Charlie Cox has broken his silence
return to the MCU
he's been embattled somewhere
so he said quote I thought it was a joke
or a prank I got a message from Kevin
feige's assistant saying can you call us
back I thought it might be for a charity
event on account of coping and everyone
would attend but I was asked if I wanted
to be in Spider-Man it was crazy and boy
was it crazy uh you guys ever forget
that blind act or blind characters
aren't blind in real life like every
time Charlie Cox can see I'm like wait
that's not right do you hear about him
having a hard time on auditions for
years because he kept looking past the
cash directors no I didn't know because
he was so easy to playing Glenn that he
struggled I did love it she hooked that
she calls it out where it's like if
you're not actually blind
I don't know I don't know it works for
him uh it works and finally it seems as
though Marvel's website has officially
confirmed the Netflix Daredevil series
as Canon I'm speechless on this but
we'll talk about it uh while the
character was teased earlier in the
season he's this is what the website
says I apologize they say while the
character was teased earlier in the
season he's finally reintroduced two
audiences in episode 8 of Marvel Studio
She-Hulk turning out law and he's very
much the same Matt Murdoch audiences
have come to know and love over the
years once again played by Charlie Cox
returning to the role now we believe you
and I that this could be in 19 years
this is like interns gotta fill out the
thing in the morning and no one double
checked this and find he's like bring
him the wording is also very it's the
same Matt Murdoch like if if it's a very
no one love over the years like he's a
character on cheat right right they're
like it's the same old Frasier guys I
mean he's still having pre-marital sex
which I would think Daredevil would not
do is it's about Catholic man uh but he
he certainly went through some women
before I'm married
back in your case but I don't know
because Charlie Cox himself kind of
insinuated that this is a different
version of it yeah and then I don't know
like all but I don't understand this is
this is the case Charlie Cox versus
Marvel intern right Marvel's got a lot
of websites to fill out a lot of like
episode descriptions to write and I
don't think everything's getting double
checked they run browsers right I don't
know if they were on browsers but one
day
well canonically we have to get some of
those starlets into the once a year
don't we at some point we have to uh but
we're very excited because page and born
again oh my gosh we are very excited to
see Daredevil finally make his
appearance on uh Shield last night and
this is a good time to let you all know
that our our friends over at epic hero
shop we have a new shirt out on the
website today uh celebrating the return
of Daredevil to the MCU I mean he
returned in Spider-Man toy home but
that's technically
he's The Devil's Advocate baby he's back
he did a great job on the show so check
out that shirt uh and all of our awesome
merch options over on new
rockstarsmerch.com but let's talk about
this episode
last night She-Hulk finally brought Matt
Murdock in
with a bag so proud of himself so proud
of himself who wrote this you did
I did from the confines of my own home
currently infested with bugs now that we
have established The Man Without Fear
it's time
to see just how this leads us into
Daredevil born again and koi I think you
have some ideas right so I do but I'm
really curious because one this is a
very dark Source material for Daredevils
to adapt and I think what's gonna be
complicated don't drop those are very
expensive Daredevil uh
Daredevil has been is
the uh 13 sourced show and arguably
Frank Miller's darede born again is the
most dark of the Daredevil arcs uh when
you look at it's also the source for the
season three run on Netflix so it's
gonna be really interesting is it's
based on a run wherein things couldn't
get worse for Matt so it's a really bold
way to reintroduce uh Matt Murdoch to
audiences uh but I do think it kind of
works plotline wise because Daredevil's
identity is the source of his troubles
in Daredevil born again right so you've
got Daredevil basically uh yeah
you can do your regularly four years old
sorry so you've got Daredevil basically
in born again uh ratted out by Karen
Page who is a heroin addict and has
fallen on hard times and has gotten into
porn and not kidding this is the way the
story goes this is the story this is
nice
so basically uh things couldn't go more
awry for Karen and she sells out Matt
Murdoch's identity in order to basically
get one more shot of hero have gone
really badly so she sells him out to
Kingpin Kingpin then uses his weight to
basically pressure the IRS into freezing
Matt Murdock's assets and then Matt has
to basically uh live on the streets and
a lot of that is what they turned into
season three of the Netflix show wherein
he lives in the church he's nursed back
to health by the same uh Priestess nurse
what do they call those women
priesterers nuns the nuns you described
like she was part of the Castlevania
friend you know I call those ghoulish
priests
and black with a white around their
faces none well she was definitely part
of some weird little extra nut occult
yeah a little extra yeah no such thing
as an extra none of them
sisterhoods so remind me in the
Daredevil Netflix series by the by the
third series Wilson fix fist did figure
out that Matt Murdoch was doing so
basically they had adapted it you know
like adaptation versus translation right
they'd adapted it to the Netflix version
of their stories what's interesting to
me is we've got got Charlie Cox saying
one thing and then we've got Marvel
saying the other thing but if it is the
same Daredevil they're going to be
retelling a lot of the story yeah and if
it's not which characters will return
will we have Karen cages do they have
those characters because if you don't
it's gonna be really confusing for
audiences to be like why is Matt the
same Endeavor right why is foggy and
then of course Luke Cage whereas where's
everybody yeah yeah so that that's good
no one's asking where Iron Fist did say
he was willing to come back yeah
he's just sitting in his outfit waiting
just doing he's wearing his game his
phone up let's check the phone still
doing Iron Fist you need me I mean they
did did introduce uh the two the two
other dudes in the last episode of
She-Hulk so I would say that Iron Fist
has a okay Chance of coming back two
other dudes
um
red board again no do you think sorry
it's okay no no no no no no
this is this is pertinent do you think
that Disney is just being cheeky the
title works because it's moving and
they're just gonna ignore it like kind
of I correctly if I'm wrong but Infinity
War changed a lot of what the infinity
War comic yeah it's very different
totally different it's like 46. the
title is is very uh provocative the
content was not necessary yeah I mean
like married to the source you're right
time like Civil War was very different
from how it plays like bases still yeah
so that's what wondering about the base
of this requires betrayal it requires
Karen Page requires Kingpin all things
that we've been cast all things that are
very dark in the Netflix world right you
can't really do born again without the
depravity of what Netflix has to do
right so if you're doing a 16 episode
story on Disney plus I mean they push
the limits of Disney plus I think last
night and She-Hulk I don't know if
Disney plus is going to go heroin junkie
[ __ ] New Jersey Karen Page I hope
they do uh on that note we did pass our
100 Super Chat so let's get our
residents
so you want to do a little dance class
yeah but I need I need a back track I
need y'all to like create music
[Applause]
[Music]
This Is A Dancer an escape it's very
scary she said it was a little dance
okay and
and then maybe one like like
oh body roll a little sugar roll almost
too seductive wow we promised you a
little dance and that was we delivered
on our promise
oh wow a little
maybe a little smaller the people will
vote
smaller or we shut this whole show down
the people will vote if we raise 100
more dollars if you want it a little
bigger or a little smaller oh I'm
actually looking we have zero people
watching right now
immediately that's exactly what happened
to my twitch stream too no
um Corey you mentioned like the name
thing being a big deal and born again uh
in this episode of She-Hulk obviously
we learned that the sokovia Accords have
been repealed which was shocking news
flippantly like just a very easily
written it was like we all know this
yeah
wait who knows this like I'm wondering
if the people were writing Captain
America New World Order like no that
this is Jeff Jeff love this is like
uh like pretty Shaggy and stuff but this
would be a big deal right because the
jacobia Accords uh they they fleshed it
out more on Agents of Shield but we
would hear things here and there and
part of it was like if you have
superpowers you have to register with
like the United Nations they have to
know your identity uh and that has to be
made done if you don't do that you're in
violation you can be hunted down and
thrown in the raft or whatever uh now
now we're in this place where this is an
MCU where most people know who most
people are people know Sam Wilson is
Captain America that he was a falcon
people know Tony that was the big change
of Marvel right they started off like
Iron Man by saying hey I'm Iron Man and
that was shocking because most superhero
movies are about protecting your
identity right but that seems to have
gone out the way no matter how
ridiculous it is right right Clark Kent
Daredevil not Matt Murdoch he knows law
but not too much he watches a lot of TV
that Superhero is very litigious his
stubble looks very familiar but I I do
think that the reason they can use
dirtable in a specific way is one you've
got the law elements and you've also got
the Miss Marvel timing so in Miss Marvel
looks like the dodc is going to be kind
of a king into the Civil War and I
talked about kamala's law a few times
where they do it uh the Scoville Accord
basically doesn't go through so they may
get young Heroes right so like kids
under 18 can't be superheroes right so
it'd be interesting if Daredevil is then
thrown in the Forefront of someone who's
revealed identity and you're fighting
for people's rights because this whole
episode I think the reason that he was
defending that you know psoist was not
in order to really protect him but to
protect all of his other superhero folk
it looked like it was a personal thing
so I'd imagine that might come into play
and born again and obviously born again
with the title of the pun of born Indian
Christian he's someone that's you know
brought back they might make it more
about being born again exposed like what
if he's born again of revealed he met
murder I mean there's also comic story
lines uh there's this great Mark Wade
run where he's literally revealed to be
at Murdoch and he wears uh a t-shirt
into court that says I'm not Daredevil
and basically just it doesn't he Sue
himself to try and prove it Rob Gail had
wrote a uh the guy who wrote Back to the
Future did like five Comics that was all
Daredevil suing himself to try and prove
he's not or Matt Murdoch suing Daredevil
that's a real misdoubt fire Center yeah
objection
so that that could be how they do it
again right they can be born again as
someone with a you know a revealed
identity and you know that would just
leave spiders you know he he well so in
this most recent episode of She-Hulk he
was very much fighting for her to do
both sides as the you know people well I
guess he's already a lawyer and a
superhero but maybe he was trying to
influence her maybe she'll influence him
to live his life a little more publicly
and I love that line because the whole
show right all all seven episodes up
until this episode of Shield were about
her trying to fight to be comfortable as
Jen in the dating world or come from a
She-Hulk and embracing her She-Hulk side
and I love that depending on the episode
they did different body language with
where she was more comfortable what she
was more identifying with and then to
have Matt Murdock come in as the voice
of this is how you can help Society this
is so you can help with the law fails
and it kind of United She-Hulk and Hulk
and then to end the episode with that
being all ripped apart it'd be
interesting if then that happens to Matt
so what if Matt who's now found his
rhythm found his place as someone who
identifies with both identities after
three seasons now has to learn the
upheaval of one thing born again as a
different version himself and that's
exactly what I was saying I was just
trying to save some time I'm like
dancing in a little bit but that was
pretty much nailed it nice
hey
it's no secret that our viewing audience
disgusts me between the back alley
dumpsters and side street cans it's
exhausting to deal with all of you your
chats your prattling on in the chat that
I have to read except for the Buffalo
Bills fan so I love and I live in
mansions and are special boys and girls
anyway fortunately I can typical of G
fuel return to homeostasis oh okay guess
what tonight before werewolf By Night
I'ma mix the flavors what that I mean
that's a horrible idea I'm gonna mix
some flavors and make a Super G fuel no
one can stop me Zach ain't here the only
person I fear on this show is Zach and
he's not here when Zach's away the T-man
gets to play okay what if there's like a
chemical reaction there won't be a
reaction stable Anna I'm scared I'm a
boy I know science and math no it can't
be if it explodes you'll do it I'm safe
I gotta live to dance
she lives today
that's that's for the courts to decide
Tommy all right listen I used to work at
a haunted house okay you don't get too
deep anyway
check out the Rick and Morty theme G
fuel flavor unstable portal fluid you
know I know unstable which you can get
is a tub or in a collector's box which
comes with a shaker cup featuring The
titular characters Rick and Morty oh I'm
told they mean a lot to the show G2 I'm
just kidding I used to do Rick's plane
remember that now Whitney owning the
breakdowns you better watch my girl
she's crushing those breakfast if you
also have some fun Halloween themed
flavors and packs including hocus pocus
focus starter kits and a candy corn
pumpkin bundle now I once was told I was
gonna shoot a scene that had a candy
corn pumpkin bundle and it was very
different anyway click the link in the
description and use the code new
rockstars to get 30 off your order use
the code it only saves you guys a little
cash which you could desperately use you
impoverished peasants but it also helps
us to create more of this sweet sweet
content and that's not the only sponsor
we want to thank today I believe
we're also going to thank epic hero shop
yeah well did you already think I did
mention it yeah be sure to check out new
rockstarsmerge.com they got a new
Daredevil shirt up on the site right now
check it out for sure and I also want to
thank our other sponsor zachies khakis
oh yeah yeah Zach Huddleston uh sources
only the finest khaki materials and
makes trousers so nice that you can wear
them from your sternum to your Burnham
it's time for mandatory fun it's a tough
a tough Subway
transition
[Music]
the segments because it was so bad the
segment so provocative
that we have to play the graphic on top
of it yeah I like that one oh yeah
the segment that's not addressing the
absence of Anna playing the graphic
again oh yeah baby
it's a segment so much fun
that we just gotta have some hit the
graphic again now I want to mention
something weird has been happening in
the office not just my usual guess that
scent you know I like to drop little
sense everywhere yeah yeah make people
guess usually it's poison uh there's
been quizzes little pop quizzes just
showing up on people's desks a little
multiple times I said notice one of them
and we're all like this is weird is
Philip testing us are we all about to
get canned is he gonna fire us again
I've been fighting six times from this
coming it's true you won't leave seven
times the term seven year Niche uh
anyway we've got quizzes all over we
know it can't be the quiz Master because
there's no way being waterboarded right
now a quizzle quizzes
answered me these questions
oh you decide to have him back huh I
really I think you set that up for
yourself Tommy you really was talking
about it oh no gobblers
in this house
if you didn't know you did know because
you have heard the the rumors I'm back
your mustache is looking much better wow
yeah what a glow up for the quizzes yeah
yes I found my Top Hat a squirrel stole
it last week a squirrel I killed the
mother
language first of all apologies yeah
apologies in schools I uh I was
vacationing in Guantanamo and I'm back
now because I have this quiz by the way
I noticed you [ __ ] didn't
complete any of the questions I left you
whoa you could just cause other
Christian names okay Jessica I noticed
that you didn't fill out any oh it is
weird having two jokes you said her name
when she appeared in the hallways I
think everyone the quiz master has too
much power man let me try something
William shed
I don't know anyway chat Daddy tell us
about our quizzes today quiz Master
have a little more [ __ ] enthusiasm on
your elders
Elders man please Master remind us how
old are you 280
at your ears clean canonically 285.
slimony well today oh look no one wrote
me a teleprompter that's fine I'll
improvised we didn't know you were gonna
do oh my gosh one thing we know about
the quiz Master hurls people under the
bus very high maintenance when you offer
the quiz Master help they do a lot of
like no I'm fine don't worry about it I
got this then we get to the show and the
quiz Master falls apart quiz Master is a
house of cards I demand and excellence
and I don't think there's anything wrong
with that you shouldn't either you're
respect your elders now I assume since
you need something to say I assume
there's questions or more answer them is
there it's a quiz why would I be here if
not to quiz you are you gonna keep track
of this time of the answer of course I
always keep track we know this how did
you get here do you have a card
are you licensed to drive
what that's not legal
oh my God two of them
uh same time I have quiz you take quiz
do you even know what the prize is today
from you I pass I reject the prize the
prize will be whoever wins I will tell
them exactly what they've always wanted
to hear oh okay so there's
[Applause]
Dave and Buster's has brought back the
mini hot dogs oh yes that's what I've
always you're drinking my drink
smells like someone trying to take my
bit I don't I don't know
[Applause]
take your big quiz master I respect you
and I fear you because I'm your Elder
now we have to get to these questions or
I'll never leave and I want to leave so
badly
I'm asking questions about old [ __ ]
horror movies no uh question one we're
jumping into it what does the monster in
Frankenstein do that causes an uproar or
is it a destroys a church B kills a
priest or a um what do you call them the
uh nurse nurse church people that's on
you boy she's making fun of you is it C
throws a little girl into a lady hooks
up with morbius which is the answer
write it down on your foreign
did make me watch some old okay well we
have a c we have a c and an a from the
loser over here oh my God Frankenstein
she's a monster right I like that no one
ever guesses frankincense right inside
the monster I'm sorry Max Savage and
painter I liked that you did give it a
good guess but you're a wrong idiots so
try again next time a little harder
please no question number two
nosfarato originated from which country
gotta put a little spice on it is it a
France B Germany C Austria or D
Atlantica it might be Ariel's cousin
have you ever thought of it why are you
shouting at me Austria was one of those
Austria one of them is Austria which one
who sees Austria what day is France B is
Germany D is Atlantica the other D was
hooked up with morbius did anyone laugh
oh someone left you that joke but I'm
scared to respond to you I went with
Austria oh okay and a b who remembers
what that was why do I keep holding
me oh I got two points I'm doing good
I'm gonna hear what I've always wanted
to hear wait no scratches not from
Transylvania have I been misled that's
Dracula oh they're different no he's a
sparkling vampire come on
question number three how tall was the
model ape used to make King Kong we're
Captain King Kong as a monster shut up a
18 inches B 15 inches C 12 inches or D
exactly Coy's height
um when you say model eight do you mean
an ape a live Vape they're using as the
model because now I'm picturing a tiny
little gorilla I hear it's not precise
well did you hear the [ __ ] answers
they're all very small
oh it's true all right
I literally wrote my own that's the size
of the Apes it's the bundle in the
jungle yeah
uh Jessica here got it
Tommy gets one Jessica to my right got
it I'm crying Jessica to my left looking
Flyers hey girl what's up anyway I'm
taken
wait okay so quiz Master canonically is
in a relationship
or he's in an open relationship
relationships are for human beings
you're not human well they could still
be human they could just also say
relationships oh my God it's so
uncomfortable either human or I'm not
technically the quiz Masters monster yes
thank you now what are we on four or
five I think we're on four now I know
how you guys always feel you're already
King I hope you like King Kong we got
another King Kong
I had so much time to write these and I
went with two King Kong questions it's
interesting uh
a two B three C four or D there haven't
been any society as we know it is an
illusion
there's I'm gonna say there's more but
I'm gonna say there's more than sea
offers
wow there's the old Harry house in one
there's like the one
the one with Jack Black there's two
based in the Godzilla Universe
at minimum five well you the answer
today and I won't explain anything
you know what the worst part is we don't
have our researcher Anna here to find
out I know she could let us know first
of all respect your [ __ ] Elders
quiz master I think you have to dance
uh quiz Master quizzes it's see right
there in the [ __ ] name oh it looks
like Annabelle
that's not fair
I didn't
I will give one quiz Master dance uh
butt animal also dance but you'll get
one thing from quiz Masters oh boy do we
do we have any more questions
what oh are you on my clothes yeah I'm
on camera four more trust me the camera
is on you right now do you have any more
questions one more question oh you keep
folding that up yeah you just leave it
on the bottle also I don't I think I
don't think this is movies that King
Kong was in I think it's a King Kong
movie like okay I still stand by myself
Godzilla I would say by definition yeah
a couple of movies in King Kong is in is
the King Kong okay
number five the last question and then
I'm Gone Forever what I'm back to my
grassy knoll after this what is the
setting for the thing a Siberia okay I'm
trying to work out out what Corey said
in between my sentences I think we've
identified you as the assistant
glasses keep
s ministering us do you even remember
the question no I'm ready
I know what is the setting for the thing
a Siberia B Alaska C Antarctica or
decoy's mom's house
which thing definitely a thing at Cory's
mom my dancers only see
hey just so you know
and the answer to this one is
congratulations [ __ ] losers who got
the most points it's like Tommy won this
one Tommy I'm Tommy coming with five
correct names nicely done tell me what
I've always wanted to hear Tommy for
this one I'm going to have to role play
as your father oh I'm proud of you son
oh
she's right we have eight more horse
funerals lined up this month no phony
horses I must have wave
this magical human Elixir can you send
Anna back did you see her in the hallway
if I see if I see her I'll try because
thank you to the quiz Master
uh thank you to all our super Chatters
out there we begin a lot of
superchargers we really appreciate it oh
man Aaron Storm's saying big dance
that's right we want to see a big dance
from everyone she comes back yeah
I'm calling it quiz Master as a power
bottom I don't know what that means
I agree with that Jay Ryan Melia saying
you wackaduce you whack it I just got
word that about eight horses died
outside
I need a race track are they filming
luck Seasons
well there's no feedback in the game hey
you ran a poll you have to do a big
dance a bigger dance in the last
here we go uh bet your song for a bigger
dance
before we start I want to preface oh
this is only a little bigger okay you
can vote a little bigger I will say
you're not low mates
[Music]
[ __ ] you lose
[Music]
oh my god wow
that's right
ouch I did what I did that was tough I
did it again toxic good good Britney I'm
not gonna let that go yeah a little
bigger if you want any bigger than that
we'll see uh let's see yeah we did have
lots of super chats to get you over the
threshold there Anna uh
I didn't see one that I did really like
oh bear trap124 offering to You Tommy
from your mug sipper to your coffee
dripper I like that one I like that one
Chris hockley's saying which other
superheroes do you think have big has
experienced an in-suit walk of shame I
loved that moment yeah what a guy wow
Deadpool if he could feel shame
Deadpool's gonna walk I mean there was
literally no reason for him to still
have his shoes on like he could have
just put his shoes back on you gotta
touch grass touch grass of shame in the
sexual way but like Batman uh forever
when Nicole Kidman tells uh Batman that
she's got feelings for Bruce Wayne and
like kicks him out and he has to walk
yeah yeah in the Batman suit and then he
just Smiles
a little bit you know I don't I don't I
you know the term walk of shame I think
has negative connotations but I'm sure
like black wet on that you know she's
dipped out on a few folks uh while the
country is falling apart oh my God
for sure so rich he probably makes it
look amazing yeah it doesn't Tony Stark
doesn't leave his house for hookups are
you joking well I mean famously in the
first one right it has pepper deal with
it but surely he's been in like a whole
hotel room where he's like I gotta leave
oh my God she's dead Ray Donovan I think
they call him happy you know you know
the reason that that uh Happy make me
smile
get this bad girl out of the room and
make me smile Howard and Tony had an icy
relationship because a young Tony needed
Howard to get rid of a body okay what
happened to her I brought the party
uh I think Nick Fury's probably had a
walk of shame probably I mean Peter
Quill definitely has with many different
places the power broker yeah you're a
misdefining walk of shame I think he's
like you go to someone's house right one
night stand and then you walk home yes a
shame and late
you have no other name I would say
welcome same as the negative in [ __ ]
strut is the positive and that's okay
anytime I walk it's a walk of shame no
matter the other no matter what it's
just watched right I wouldn't except I
was a happy member anytime I walk it's a
[ __ ] strap yeah
oh I'm gonna dick ourselves out of this
one well I'm looking through some of our
super checks we had a lot of love for
the quiz Master which I don't understand
God please stop asking for the quiz
Master to return those Emerson white
pointed out the quiz Master is supposed
to have canonically a deer stalker oh I
don't believe that's right so much about
the quiz Master but if you recall the
quiz Master complained very early on in
their first appearance about not getting
enough notice so they couldn't wear the
correct hair early on in Uncanny X-Men
they called Scott summer slim Summers
and that never came back again Powers
change often from early Comics they call
Wolverine knife hands in the first
couple episodes oh okay they're like
knifey hands knife get over here get on
over here he's like I gotta come up with
a better name bub
um someone saying stride to Pride I like
that too oh yeah
Thank You kylo Ren that I didn't expect
to come from kylo Ren but hey he comes
from who it comes from uh who who kylo
Ren has had a stride of Pride from right
every time they did very well every time
oh you still got it going on kylo uh he
never does a stride of Pride because he
stays in the room
no
no I wanted to shoot him with everything
you have
um
he's just like I hope this was as good
as my grandfather uh John Chung now I'm
eating nachos
John Chung was asking will it be a
latest Obsession shirt for Andor and
werewolf by night I think there is and
some indoor shirts right now I think
there's going to be a werewolf finally
rumors on air we did we did it's not
technically
is that a yes Phillip tomorrow
are you yeah these are not are you just
hanging out it's just getting pleasure
there won't be a latest Obsession but we
heard from the boss's mouth that there
will be a werewolf finite related shirt
dropping tomorrow hey because we had so
many super chats can I just like run
through the names real quick to thank
everyone I think that'd be real nice
yeah yeah I tried to hit a bunch of them
we had some some double ups but uh
okay I'm gonna do my best sorry if I
miss anyone uh thank you Robin thank you
Matt thank you how's the wrong time
thank you Everson white thanks MJ thanks
uh uh uh uh you know your name is
unpronounceable Christian that's it
right unpronouncable yeah thank you Lily
B thank you Ali and
my eyes very very hard to see the quiz
master has great eyesight he's got more
than 20 20. okay that day yeah we don't
know what they are yeah I'm sorry I
can't believe I just got gatekeeps well
to be fair Anna we were here when the
quiz
each other last time we passed each
other okay okay okay well great thank
you everyone though and bear chat thank
you bear track uh we can't have Phil
come on camera because you spelled his
name wrong and he doesn't go by that
yeah that's right get it right or pay
the price hey folks make sure you stay
up late tonight we'll get up early
tomorrow morning to watch a little
werewolf by night I'm afraid to watch it
because I'm scaredy boy but we are going
to be celebrating werewolf by night
tomorrow we're gonna have a very spooky
show you guys tomorrow Tommy's already
practicing Tommy's mixing G fuels
tonight to stay up for it he feels left
and right it's gonna be amazing I don't
think you can call them that uh uh make
sure you tune in tomorrow wrap up your
week here with us on the break room live
from our very own break room right here
at new Rockstar's headquarters uh check
out the Discord if you haven't already
uh thanks for all your super chats today
thanks for being a part of the show
thanks for tuning in uh we hope you have
a great rest of your Thursday we'll see
you right here tomorrow same time don't
miss it
it's Frankenstein
[Music]